my mind is like I've literally never
heard of this before I'm extremely
nervous because I don't know if this is
gonna ruin a lot of my favorite foods
for me I'm scared it won't work on me
and then I'll find out I have like
faulty tastebuds or something this looks
like drugs it tastes how I imagined
poker really taste I'm ready to flavor
trip balls whoa oh my god
new pulling sugar in loose it's so good
I got actually heat like an entire bag
of lemons on this stuff oh my god I'll
taste [ __ ] delicious it tastes like
lemonade a little hold on I'm gonna have
another one let's just fill that right
up it tastes like barefoot Moscato that
you buy when you had like three dollars
in college this is like Capri Sun like
Island taste anything besides like juice
this just tastes like water down coffee
just tastes like water
it tastes like pee I have tasted you
before Oh disgusting if I drank this and
somebody told me I was apple juice I'd
be like you need to throw this out this
is like a week past the expiration date
that was more pleasant than I expected
it's still just as potent as you'd
expect apple cider vinegar to be but
it's sweet this is so weird
how long does this last forever babies
like to see her hurt it's so rude it's
like a to come alright that's not even
that one has it ruined my trip has the
jalapeno ruined my flavor trip
this is my worst enemy I think
recruiting is like vile whoa wow this
tastes like a tangerine this is so sweet
I can't believe grapefruits are not
trash and nobody told me that that was
probably one of the most life-changing
experiences I've had I will not do this
again
it was fun I hope I don't get addicted
to like little flavor taste bud Messer
upper pills let's have dinner after this
is all going to taste like chewy candy
mastery a coated advil tastes better
than this
so get sick reject Flintstones gummy
here's a cut I imagine like a Gucci
perfume I taste like too expensive but
disgusting